et as salam et votre invité ce matin et
président du groupe l'est républicain au
sénat
oui bonjour bruno retailleau bonjour
l'islam et merci d'être avec nous ce
matin voilà dominique seux vient de
préciser les choses encore plus
clairement on a depuis hier soir le plan
en trois étapes du déconfinement en
clair première étape le week-end
prochain
deuxième étape le 15 décembre 3e étape
le 20 janvier si tout va bien vous
demandiez à emmanuel macron avant son
allocution je vous cite de la clarté une
perspective et du bon sens
avez vous entendu tout cela hier soir
êtes-vous satisfait ce matin
partiellement gelée trouvait sans doute
plus tendue que d'habitude mais aussi
plus précis que d'habitude il a donné
une perspective en donnant des échéances
le bon sens oui et non on est toujours
un peu dans l'absurde is temps quand on
voit par exemple pour les cultes la
limitation à 30 fidèles quelles que
soient la chapelle où la grande
cathédrale ça veut dire que dans une
grande cathédrale vous aurez moitié
moins de personnes que par exemple dans
une voiture de tgv dont coin on est
toujours dans la nature distant mais en
tout cas il ya une perspective
la question maintenant la grande
question c'est est-ce que mails macron
fera demain notamment en termes de
méthode pour reprendre le contrôle de
l'épidémie
ce qu'il n'a pas su faire durant ces
neuf derniers mois c'est toute la
question de la méthode sur le dépistage
sur le traçage et sur l' isolement alors
justement il a reconnu que la stratégie
tester tracé isolée n'avait pas
pleinement marché l'a dit hier il veut
ouvrir un débat au parlement pour
sanctionner plus durement ceux qui ne
s'isole pas quand ils sont testés
positifs ça existe dans d'autres pays
avec des amendes très lourdes être est
ce que vous êtes favorable moi je suis
pas favorable pour l'obligation pour la
vaccination je suis pas non plus
favorable pour l'isolément je pense en
revanche qu'on peut avoir un isolement
qui soit à la fois contrôler un peu
comme les arrêts maladie d'ailleurs et
qu'ils soient mieux accompagnés
mais avant de le rendre obligatoire
faut-il le rendre possible parce que
souvenez vous dans le premier
confinement il ya d'un grand groupe
hôtelier qui avait mis à disposition des
auteurs il ya eu personne en réalité il
ya une volonté à avoir
mais au-delà de ça il ya une stratégie
de dépistage qui pour l'instant a échoué
il faut une méthode cibler les plus de
65 ans
fragil dépister toutes les semaines les
ehpad il faudra aussi tracé là aussi
grande faillite le traçage si on veut
reprendre
justement la main le contrôle de
l'épidémie il faut tracer les kloster
comment fait-on à partir des stations
d'épuration on l'a fait à l'île d'yeu en
vendée on le fait aussi à marseille puis
ensuite on va tester plus finement il
faut faire sur tout ce que les japonais
les allemands commencent à faire c'est à
dire un traçage rétroactif rétrospectif
pour remonter et pour trouver dans la
chaîne de contamination pour trouver les
super contaminateur parce qu'on sait
désormais que environ 15% des cas
positifs contamine son responsable à peu
près 80 à 90%
donc comme on peu pas tracé tout le
monde est bien traçons au moins les
super contaminateur c'est ça la méthode
c'est ce que je demande d'ailleurs
depuis le départ au gouvernement et à
emmanuel macron la vaccination
commencera dès fin décembre début
janvier pour les plus fragiles et les
plus âgés il y aura ensuite une campagne
de vaccination pour tout le monde
nous serons prêts au rendez-vous du
vaccin a dit hier emmanuel macron êtes
vous rassuré sur ce plan là non je ne
serai rassuré que dans les faits parce
que depuis écouter on pour le premier
confinement et faire des masques ennuis
on a eu ensuite cet été-là faire des
tests donc on voit bien qu'on a la
machine bureaucratique française qui
pourtant emploie beaucoup beaucoup de
monde et souvent inefficaces simplement
faisons attention c'est fondamental ce
sera un acte de générosité
je me ferai vacciner il faudra
convaincre les français qu'ils sont
parmi les peuples européens les moins
convaincus le plus réticent le plus
réticent bien sûr je suis j'apporte
juste une nuance à ce que je disais je
pense que quand même pour le personnel
soignant dans les ehpad je pense qu'il
faut vraiment qu'ils puissent être
vaccinés parce que ils peuvent être des
vecteurs d'introduction dans ces lieux
clos avec des personnes fragiles là je
pense qu'on peut se poser la question de
l'obligation vaccinale sur ceux sur ses
personnages six nations à méga teuf pour
l'espagne je serai en tout cas engageant
un débat y compris avec les personnels
de santé
mais très franchement quand je vois mon
les ehpad ça peut être dramatique
les aides sont renforcées pour les
restaurants bars cafés qui ne pourront
pas rouvrir avant le 20 janvier au plus
tôt ils pourront donc toucher 20 % leur
chiffre d'affaires de 2010
9 vous dites c'est bien ou combien ça va
encore nous coûter cette mesure moi je
pense que il faut continuer à travailler
il faut pas se résoudre au 20 janvier je
pense qu'on va perdre des dizaines de
milliers d'entreprises restaurateurs
bars etc
vous dites il faut ouvrir les
restaurants plutôt qu'il faut il faut
tâcher de le faire en tout cas je ne
suis pas péremptoire je pense qu'il faut
travailler pour le faire comment
travailler pour les commerces je ne peux
pas vous dire mais en tout cas on peut
pas se résoudre à sa commune une
fatalité
je pense qu'il faut faire attention faut
concilier l'économie et puis aussi le
sanitaire mais ça c'est un impératif
oui c'est à dire il faut vous ne vous
résignez pas non je ne me résigne pas je
pense qu'on peut travailler peut-être
que l'ouverture par exemple pour le
déjeuner etc
je ne veux pas de pré emploi parce que
je sais que c'est difficile simplement
il faut mettre les gens autour de la
table il faut discuter avec moi je me
suis battue depuis le départ pour
l'ouverture des commerces de proximité
parce que c'est elle absurdistan parce
que c'était incroyable qu'on puisse pas
acheté chez son libraire au coin de la
rue son livre alors qu'on pouvait aller
dans ta porte graine quelle grande
surface donc je crois que bien sûr le
gouvernement dépense c'était votre
question il sait ce que c'est mais il
fait ce que les hommes et les femmes
politiques en france savent le mieux
faire dépenser l'argent qu'ils n'ont pas
dépenser l'argent des fautes
la france sortira de cette affaire
affaibli plus que beaucoup d'autres pays
européens plus que beaucoup d'autres
pays dans le monde
elle sortira pardon à idées à cause du
quoi qu'il en coûte à cause du quoi
qu'il en coûte bien sûr pour la première
fois peut-être que dominique se lancer
pour la première fois l'état va
emprunter cette année plus que ce qu'il
va gagner on va emprunter environ 260
milliards sur les marchés financiers
et on va les recettes fiscales c'est 250
milliards on peut pas ne pas
s'interroger
évidemment les hommes politiques savez
là de la meilleure devise homme
politique français c'est je dépense donc
je suis parce que la dépense créé
l'illusion d'une forme de puissance de
pouvoir je ne dis pas que y avait-il le
choix là quand il y avait un chômage
qu'elle ait explosé fall est évidemment
non j'étais un des tout premiers dans un
grand quotidien
économique le 11 mars a proposé un
certain nombre de pistes qui ont
d'ailleurs été reprises simplement vous
savez même avant la crise même avant le
plan de relance la france dans les
shales dans le classement des pays les
mieux gérés
nous sommes à l'avant dernier rang avec
la roumanie
donc la crise sanitaire elle a bon dos
pour ne pas faire les réformes qu'on
aurait dû faire bien sûr avant et kemmel
mâcon n'a pas fait ne croyez pas ce qu'a
dit emmanuel macron hier on ressortira
plus fort de cette crise on a analysé
nos faiblesses on est en train de les
corriger
la bureaucratie tout ça il a dit moi je
suis je suis près comment dire
évidemment qu'il faut être modeste bien
sûr est évidemment que c'est un choc est
brutal mais on peut se comparer et quand
on se compare on se console pas on se
désole plus tôt je pense qu'il a pas
bien protégé les français la france le
taux de mortalité est quand même pas des
taux de mortalité important en europe
alors qu'on a la première dépense de
santé
et puis je pense que la france sera
affaibli l'état plus efficace
est ce que les français se sont rendus
compte que nous avions désormais 1 étape
plus efficace non on est dans l'absurde
distants bruno retailleau de trois
questions sur d'autres sujets le projet
de loi sécurité globale pour protéger
les policiers a été voté hier à
l'assemblée nationale il arrive au sénat
le sénateur de votre groupe philippe bas
veut modifier le fameux article 24 qui
pénalise la diffusion malveillantes
d'image de policiers en affirmant qu'il
est inutile pour les policiers
inapplicable inconstitutionnelle et
qu'il représente une atteinte à la
liberté d'informer est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec tout ça je confirme que
nous sommes avec fille bail avec
françois noël buffet qui préside
désormais la commission des lois
nous sommes en train de travailler à une
rédaction
il ya une très mauvaise rédaction on va
essayer de faire en sorte de clarifier
les choses notamment en matière pénale
notamment pour réserver sur notamment
les services électroniques internet pour
dégager la presse et les journalistes de
ce qui pourrait être en réalité un
empêchement de faire son travail
et puis il faut aussi quand même
protéger les policiers les gendarmes
donc le sénat et c'est un peu notre
savoir faire d'un point de vue technique
juridique nous sommes en train d'y
travailler pour trouver ce chemin de
crête
nous trouverons les images lundi soir du
camp de migrants délogés par la police
place de la république ont choqué gérald
darmanin qui a saisi l'igpn
vous ont-elles choqué également non mais
moi je suis du côté de la police qu'il y
ait des dérapages
il faut les sanctionner évidemment des
dérapages individuels ce que je veux
dire c'est que la façon la plus
solennelle qui soit la faute à qui la
faute à des activistes d'extrême gauche
d'avoir organisé cet événement parce que
ceux qui pensent en france que ça s'est
produit comme ça que tout à coup place
de la république
il ya eu un rassemblement de migrants
qui a eu des robes noires des avocats
qui a eu des caméras ça n'était pas du
tout quelque chose qui avait été
spontanément réalisé c'était évidemment
organisé donc c'est donc c'est une
provocation
et quand on a des provocations on
endosse la responsabilité
ensuite qui peut y avoir dix secondes
vous vouliez parler l'arménie pourquoi
parce que au sénat cet après midi nous
allons voter une résolution importante
qui va reconnaître la république
en tout cas demandé au gouvernement
français de reconnaître la république
d'artsakh du haut karabakh
c'est important parce que ce qui se
passe là bas nous concerne ici ça nous
concerne parce qu'il s'agit de mettre un
frein à l'expansionnisme islamistes
monsieur erdogan qui le fait là bas mais
qui le fait chez nous je vous rappelle à
chypre dans les eaux territoriales
grecques et puis aussi l'arménie c'est
un lien qui est multi séculaire et on
attend deux visages français et qui sont
arméniens qui nous ont prouvé qu'on
pouvait conjuguer l'amour de la grande
patrie la france et l'amour de la petite
patrie charnelle l'arménie ils ont
prouvé nos amis arméniens qu'on pouvait
être franc ce sans rien renier de ses
racines et ça c'est un beau message
aussi merci